رئيس فرقة إعدام في الجيش الروسي الخاص،
لديك جيني باغوسيان يقول إنه
متأكد من أنه ستكون هناك خسائر روسية كبيرة قريبًا
في ساحة المعركة في أوكرانيا
وخسارة الأراضي داخل روسيا
ويتوقع باغوسيان أن تلك الخسائر ستكون
كبيرة جدًا لدرجة أنه
سيتم إصدار أمر بفرق الإعدام  أعدم الجنرالات
المسؤولين عن الإخفاقات الروسية ولكن
عبر ثورة شعبية ستثور
بسبب أخطاء الجيش، سنعاني
الآن من خسائر فادحة. أنا
متأكد تمامًا من ذلك الآن، فنحن
بالتأكيد نخسر بعض الأراضي الروسية،
ووجود هذا الجزء في الاتحاد الروسي
هناك إما  سواء كنتم ثورة شعبية أو
أن مجلس الدوما سيتخذ قرارًا
بعقوبة الإعدام ويطلق عليهم النار،
وبالمناسبة أستطيع أن أخبركم
بصراحة، أعتقد أننا على بعد شهرين إلى ثلاثة
أشهر من فرق الإعدام